turning back to washington there was
swift backlash last night
over a plan to move some national guard
troops out of the capitol
lawmakers and others on social media
expressed outrage after these images of
the troops resting on the ground went
viral
the capitol police had told many of them
to move to a nearby parking garage
while that order was quickly rolled back
as senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge reports
this was the moment national guard
troops left a parking garage heading
back inside the capitol where only hours
earlier they were asked to leave
the capitol's hallways had served as a
warm place of rest for the troops
patrolling outside protecting the
building in the wake of the deadly riots
two weeks ago
the guard told cbs news the troops were
asked to leave by capitol hill police on
thursday afternoon
citing an increase in foot traffic with
congress in session
about 3 500 soldiers were moved from the
rest area in the capital's hallways
and relocated to the parking garage
which according to the guard had heat in
bathrooms
but some soldiers described a facility
with limited restrooms
internet service and power outlets
lawmakers expressed outrage on social
media
showing troops resting on the cement
floors and columns
this is unconscionable and unsafe
tweeted republican senator tim scott
well democratic senator and retired
guard member tammy duckworth tweeted
they can use my office just before
midnight
service members were permitted back
inside the capitol to a designated area
for their shift breaks
in the days leading up to wednesday's
inauguration more than 25 thousand
national guard members formed a
protective ring around the city
after rioters invaded the capitol on
january 6.
on thursday a sweep of those who
attacked the building continued
with at least nine new arrests including
christopher grider
who according to documents claimed the
president asked people to come
it's kind of why i came and dominic
madden seen here wearing a q anon hoodie
both were charged with violent entry
into the capitol
in a statement to cbs news the capitol
hill police said they immensely
appreciate the integral support of the
u.s national guard
in its own statement the guard said the
move to the garage was temporary and
troops are heading to hotels or other
accommodations
at the end of their shifts anthony
catherine thank you